hello she's back the queen of school
closures herself Randy Weingarten seems
to be getting a promotion in Washington
Biden's Homeland Security secretary
announcing that the left-wing teachers
union boss will be one of the new
members of a DHS academic Council the
group will provide quote strategic and
actionable recommendations to the
secretary on campus Safety and Security
improved coordination research
priorities hiring and more that sounds
great I think she'd fit right in with
the other lockdown happy bureaucrats
some lawmakers aren't too thrilled with
her new gig Florida Senator Rick Scott
tweeting quote Randy Weingarten is the
last person who should be advising
anyone on school safety end quote
judge he is not wrong about that and you
know I read the story and as the mom of
school age kids I get so mad every time
I hear her name and it's hard for me to
reconcile who did more harm during the
pandemic Anthony fauci or Randy
Weingarten the two of them and you know
what they're both considered Heroes by
the left by this Administration look you
know what's Rich about this is that
she's appointed by another failure uh
Anthony Mayer uh what's his name
Alejandro mayorcas I mean the two of
them talk about a couple of losers
um look I I think Randy Weingarten is an
embarrassment I think that our children
I mean already were behind 33 years in
math uh we're behind 20 years in Reading
uh it is sad the United States is not
what it once was and she single-handedly
is a person who didn't look for any
metric to open up the school but every
metric was to close it down and she gets
before Congress and she says oh we
wanted to open it up but people would
dying I mean give me a break the
Catholic schools were open the Lutheran
Schools were open the charter schools
were open the kids were studying quantum
physics in China and in Russia they were
studying whatever they needed to study
this woman has done more to damage this
generation of children and you know what
I'm going to cap it off with this she's
been to Ukraine three times the first
time she said she went there to compare
the education system to the United
States meanwhile every school building
had been had been totally bombed and the
kids were hiding underneath in in uh in
security places and then she keeps going
what is she doing in Ukraine why does
she keep going to Ukraine she's been
there three times you connect the dots
she's a double agent Jessica clearly um
the only thing she and Alejandro America
should be discussing is their permanent
retirement both of them they both should
resign in disgrace and the fact that
they are becoming this perfect storm of
statism they are both so anti-school
Choice uh it's it's immoral
I won't stand for it Jessica will you
sit while you're sitting down I have no
choice so
I don't think that the left likes Randy
Weingarten as much as really yeah I do I
think that she's obviously a big
figurehead she's the head of a huge
Union but I don't not that like at
liberal parties we sit around being like
you know which Union Leader are you into
but I never hear anyone saying I think
that the what happened with education
was well handled during the pandemic and
everyone is reading all of these studies
that are coming out about the learning
losses where there were Pockets where
there wasn't learning loss and the
differences in terms of people getting
vouchers then going to working in a pot
you know a pot an education pod
homeschooling whatever it was and so I
don't think that she's someone I don't
think there's like polling necessarily
out there on her popularity but I
wouldn't put her up there as
a cultural icon of the left at this
point I will say though in terms of
keeping the schools open and I think
that they ignored a lot of evidence
about how this disease was affecting
children and the stuff with you know we
have to get the desk six feet apart and
all of that she did have thousands of
teachers to deal with this wasn't
as if she woke up and said I don't want
schools open she had to deal with the
people or members of her Union saying
I'm I won't go to work but you know to
that point will she could have said get
your high knees back to school because
it was a lot of her membership that you
know they were saying well I care for a
immunocompromised person therefore I
shouldn't have to be in school so if
teachers weren't in school guess who
else wasn't in school kids and if they
were they were doing zoom in a room yeah
well to that point she doesn't represent
America's school children she represents
teachers and she will look for the best
interest at all times of teachers I'll
just share with you this quick story
Randy Weingarten sends predated the
pandemic by decades my kids went to when
we lived in New York City a charter
school up here in uptown Manhattan and
it's 75 percent black and brown it's a
charter school Success Academy and there
has been no greater enemy of the whole
Charter School movement which is a
savior to poor kids in this city 90 on
free and reduced lunch then the
existence of school choice and she has
been not just in a on it but an advocate
for destroying choice in charter schools
in this city and across this nation her
sins definitely predate the pandemic now
it's just debate on she's on the Mount
Rushmore of underrated uh destructive
forces in America with I don't know Ben
Crump and and fauci and Alejandro
mayorcas we can debate the others but
she gets here and they're so smart to
bring that up because that multi-year
study out of Stanford goes to show the
success of charter schools and they they
pointed out particularly and and this is
a nonpartisan study particularly the
charter schools in New York City and and
she along with Kathy hokel are standing
in the way of that and keeping kids in
failing schools and shame on them and
then she tried to shake down the federal
government for 750 billion dollars oh
it's a Shakedown Kennedy nail on the
head right there because this is as a
former teacher this is all a Shakedown
her big giant seven figure or six-figure
salary kid keeps getting increased she
obviously knows where the second lot
laptop is that's why she's getting promo
and gets another job I mean she has no
business representing anyone or anything
but that's kind of what we've seen with
this with unqualified people get put
into it but here's the deal let's look
at the actual job they are put together
a group of people who live in the first
world who are going to sit down and
discuss what to do in case of an
emergency besides call car service or
your personal assistant to rewrite it
for you they have no who are they
bringing in Marines are they bringing in
people who have gone through this
situation with school shootings Etc or
plans or stuff they would no it's a it's
a fabricated the whole secretary the
whole we needed it when we had 911 by my
work in them it's a ballooned up waste
of taxpayer money all they do is sit
around and just say weird ideas and pay
each other monies and go fly to Ukraine
why to get funded to get more money so
that's what it's all about at the
expense of teachers and children can I
add something really quickly um so the
governor of Pennsylvania Josh Shapiro
was on America's Newsroom this morning
and obviously big win that they rebuilt
I-95 in two weeks absolutely incredible
but he is supporting school choice in
Pennsylvania he's smart that's what
voters want and that's a Democrat and I
don't have some Democrats I know but
this is big to get a governor on the
record just saying it's what I believe
and I think that that will have a big
ripple effect through the party because
he's so they finally figured out they
should do what the parents want yeah
well it's not it's a winning issue for
any party particularly when where
parents are voting coming up Battle of
the billionaires Mark Zuckerberg is
going to fight Elon Musk the fastest is
up next stay with us hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now